Idreamt last night the moon was so bright
it melted the walls away and it wasn't alarming
when i saw Prince Charming come into my bedroom
and say
let me persuade you to come to the place where
tomorrow meets today
oh thank you it sounds very exciting may i
come just as i am Hey girls don't go to Motoramas
dressed in a pair of pink pajamas, maybe they
don't but i don't care haven't got a single
thing to wear quick please a gown oh i'll
be the talk of the town
i followed my heart through the night past
a thousand windows yellow with light down
down it fell and it landed in the Waldorf
Astoria hotel
i'm a girl who happens to think that a brand
new car is better than mink excited delighted
so glad i got invited since it's just a dream
and involves no money, which one would you
like me to buy you honey
they're all so beautiful i really don't know
so let me go down get the load on and look
at each one much closer
i want a Corvette i thought you would [Music]
oh i want a Pontiac too [Music] okay we'll
have the usual two-car garage
how do you feel about this fine Oldsmobile
it's
[Music] i'll try it
what a dreamy [Music]
let's go out and buy a cadillac too
i can hardly wait for this dream to come true
hey lady your apron is showing i better get
her into the kitchen quick
just like a man you give him a break and you
wound up in the kitchen baking a cake but
this was a kitchen like none i'd seen put
a card in the slot and onto the screen pops
a picture of just how your dish will look
plus all the ingredients you need to cook
no need for the bride to feel tragic the rest
is push button magic so whether you bake or
broil or stew the frigidaire kitchen does
it all for you don't have to be chained to
the stove all day just set the timer and you're
on your
way tick tock tick tock i'm free to have fun
around the clock
[Music]
jeepers i'm exhausted [Music] the kitchen
of tomorrow is calling me
my cake is ready [Applause] [Music] time for
the show everybody on stage
and now a glamorous dancer and a special number
dance of tomorrow
everyone says the future is strange but i
have a feeling some things won't [Applause]
change
now the dream cars of tomorrow
a magnificent eldorado town car by cadillac
ensemble by christian dior of paris
buick presents the sleek centurion driving
coat by montesano of new york
oldsmobile's elegance golden rocket sports
outfit by pat primo of los angeles [Music]
pontiac's club de mer open to the sky costume
by emilio of capri
chevrolet is impala graceful and swift silk
casual by bigby morton of london
[Music] and last of all designed for the electronic
highway of the future the fabulous turbine-powered
firebird 2.
[Music]
why it's you
firebird two to control tower we are about
to take off on the highway of tomorrow stand
by [Music]
our dreams will come true
[Music] will make
strange shapes will rise
it will be like a star burning [Music] [Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you